welcome back we're ready to do Part D
and let me copy and paste that in as
well copy and paste see I don't think
that's going to need this crap so let me
just remove that with a color other than
yellow there you go and let me copy and
paste it let's copy and paste it I don't
know if you can read it but it's helpful
for me to view the problem on the art
clipboard
okay the rate let's see okay the rate at
which tickets were sold for TVs you know
four over this range is modeled by R of
T let me write that in case you can't
see it this is the rate at which tickets
were sold R of T is equal to five fifty
T e to the minus T over two tickets per
hour based on the model how many tickets
were sold by 3:00 p.m. so my T equals
three to the nearest whole number so
that's sometimes important you don't
want to give a you don't want to give a
decimal answer so this is the rate at
which tickets are sold right so this is
the derivative of the total ticket sold
function right or another way if we
could write it is the total tickets sold
so let's call that I don't know capital
T sub well let me I don't want to do T
of T that list appears so let's say the
tickets sold the tickets sold as a
function of time is going to be equal to
the definite integral well we could it's
you could say at any time T the tickets
sold and this is the fundamental theorem
is calculus I think it might be one of
its corollaries are actually sometimes
it is the fundamental theorem calculus I
always forget my definitions but between
time equals 0 and T or if we want to
know the tickets sold between time
equals 0 and T is equal to the integral
of the rate at which the ticket sold was
changing so that's equal to 550 te to
the minus T over 2
DT alright that's it and so if we want
to know how many tickets were sold at
time equals three that's just equal to
the definite integral from zero to three
or we could also view it as the area
under this curve from time equals zero
to time equal three of five fifty T e to
the minus T over two DT now this
integral right here you can solve it
analytically using integration of parts
which I just view called the reverse
product rule but you only have 45
minutes to do all three of these
problems and they'll let you use your
graphing calculator and your graphing
calculator is excellent at use doing
definite integrals and they just want
the number right so let's use it - let's
use our graphing calculator to get that
number so let's see I want to I don't
want to copy I don't want to see so how
do we do that we just do second the
division of a division button but that's
calc definite let me let me use it the
definite integral and like what was C
let me write try that so it's 5:55 let's
just use X 550 times X times second e to
the minus X divided by 2 I think that's
the whole function right that's the
whole function and let's see my
independent variable is X I just swapped
T for X there and I'm taking the
integral from 0 to 3
click enter let the calculator do the
work this would have taken you quite a
while if you actually do the integral
yourself nine hundred seventy two point
seven eight and they want us to round to
the nearest whole number so the nearest
whole number is 973 so we say nine
hundred and seventy three tickets
tickets sold by 3:00 p.m. and we're done
that only took us four minutes and it
would take you to see even less if we
didn't have to explain it anyway I will
see you in
problem number three